la première opération de chirurgie a été
réalisé il ya au moins huit mille ans
avant même l'invention de l'écriture
aujourd'hui on va parler des premières
maladies de nos ancêtres et des tout
débuts de la médecine
ça risque d'être dense et nous serons
accompagnés pour ceux-ci de clotilde de
la chaîne passé sauvage qui va nous
parler un petit peu d'archéologie
beaucoup d'archéologie carrément très
bien générique moi c'est que le style de
la chaîne passé sauvage et je vais vous
parler de l'archéologie de cette époque
puisque c'est à peu près tout ce qu'on a
pour parler de ce sujet alors des gens
va pas parler de toute la préhistoire
parce que ça dure à peu près deux
millions d'années
et ensuite si on veut avoir des notions
sur l'état de santé des gens sans avoir
de trace écrite parce que je vous
rappelle qu'avant l'ère antique on n'a
aucune trace écrite
c'est un peu la définition du truc parce
que s'il ya bien une époque où on
commence à avoir des éléments
archéologiques c'est bien au néolithique
parce qu'on commence à construire des
sépultures le néolithique c'est une
période où il ya plein de changements
pour l'homme préhistorique l'économie
est basée sur l'agriculture et l'élevage
notamment grâce à la domestication de
plein de nouvelles espèces animales et
on commence à construire des villes
enfin c'est pas non plus une new york
mais c'est déjà plusieurs milliers de
personnes et des habitations
rudimentaire mais permanente
c'est ce qu'on appelle la
sédentarisation ça évite de courir
derrière le gibier en fonction des
saisons et pour mieux vous parler de
cette période il ya un mec à côté duquel
on peut pas passer et c'est petit à
petit est un homme qui est mort vers
3900 avant notre ère il avait 45 ans et
on a retrouvé son corps congelé avec ses
vêtements et son équipement et il est
plutôt bien conservée pour son âge non
c'est marrant parce que les momies c'est
vachement bien conservé et qu' il est
découvert dans les alpes méridionales en
1991 par un couple de randonneurs à 3210
mètres d'altitude dans le glacier de
l'ofc talent
beaucoup de choses ont été dites sur les
circonstances de sa mort on a tout
d'abord pensé qu'il était mort de froid
pris dans une tempête de neige
aujourd'hui on a finalement retenu qu'il
s'est battu et a été touché par un
projectile parce qu'on a retrouvé des
traces de sang sur ses flèches sa cape
et son poignard des traces de sang qui
appartiennent à quatre personnes
différentes
autant dire qu'il fallait pas le faire
chier au-delà de l'histoire cet homme la
découverte de ce corps est un fait
majeur pour l'archéologie de la
préhistoire
tout simplement parce qu'on a un corps
justement d'habitude on se retrouve face
à des outils au mieux des ossements de
sépulture mais cette fois c'est un corps
tout entier c'est à dire des parties
molles analyse
pau estomac intestins intestins que les
scientifiques des paléopathologiste ont
pu analyser pour connaître la
composition du dernier repas de type
alors à quoi ça nous sert de connaître
ce qu'il a mangé et bien ça nous
renseigne sur son mode de vie et surtout
son état de santé
verdict de l'analyse de ses intestins le
dernier repas de 2,6 se composait de
céréales 75% de restes végétaux de
viande de cerf et bouquetins et certains
de ces aliments aurait été cuit ses
recherches ont révélé qu'il souffrait de
pathologies diverses une intolérance au
lactose des calculs biliaires et des
problèmes cardiovasculaires dans son
estomac
on a trouvé une bactérie helicobacter
pylori et c'est cette même bactérie qui
est encore aujourd'hui responsable de
gastrite chronique
c'est à dire d'inflammation de l'estomac
et comme il consommer de la viande de
gibier probablement préparer dans des
conditions d'hygiène douteuses et pas
suffisamment cuite il était aussi
porteur de tout un tas de parasites
digestif rigolo et en particulier de
tricks in pouvant donner des diarrhées
vomissements douleurs abdominales
il est particulièrement notable qui
travaillait avec lui des champignons des
polypes hors du boulot qui sont
aujourd'hui connus pour leurs propriétés
vermifuge
ces champignons indique donc
probablement l'existence d'une
pharmacopée c'est-à-dire de végétaux
utilisés pour leurs propriétés
médicinales
dès l'époque préhistorique le cas de six
est très intéressant parce qu'il nous
donne une bonne idée du niveau de santé
des humains de cette période
mais ce qui change radicalement la donne
c'est la domestication et donc l'élevage
les hommes qui sont en contact étroit
avec des animaux domestiques et vont
bénéficier aussi de leurs maladies
infectieuses préférer les nouveaux
boulot de type berger tanner vont
largement favorisé des changes de
parasites et autres joyeusetés il faut
bien avoir en tête que jusqu'à la
révolution industrielle le travail des
hommes sans l'aide des machines mais au
contraire au contact des animaux et
pénible et surtout dangereux puisqu'il
prend place dans des lieux comme les
carrières les mines les ateliers type
forge des lieux salle où les hommes sont
bien souvent mains et pieds nus en
parlant de pieds nus il existe un métier
celui des foulons qui consiste à
piétiner des peaux de bêtes et des
tissus dans des cuves remplies d'uriné
pendant des heures ce métier existe
depuis la préhistoire mais on a une
meilleure idée de l'état de santé des
travailleurs pour l'antiquité romaine
pourquoi lui rinne bas parce qu'elle est
chargée d'ammoniaque et permet donc de
blanchir et d'assainir les pots à cela
on rajoute dans les cuves d'autres
produits naturels et super sympathique
cendres argile céréales
les cahiers souffre sulfate de fer
d'aluminium de potassium et matières
fécales le bain de pieds le plus
hardcore de l'histoire quoi ça donne
carrément l'occasion à plein de
parasites intestinaux comme les
allemands issus de matières fécales
animale et humaine dans le fameux ver
solitaire d'aller infectés de nouveaux
hôtes
d'autant que les microtraumatismes et la
macération sont des portes d'entrée
idéale pour tous les micro-organismes de
la terre on peut aussi évoquer les
pathologies ostéo-articulaires dû au
travail posté et les lésions d'arthrose
cervicales et les pathologie lombaire
que l'on constate principalement chez
les femmes de 20 ans autant dire que ça
conserve pas des masses du coup afin
d'avoir les pieds qui sont autre chose
que la fosse septique les villes
antiques vont trouver une solution les
thermes ou d'un public romain sont des
lieux implanté dans presque toutes les
cités antiques et sont très fréquentés
par le peuple c'est vrai qu'on a
tendance à les considérer seulement
comme des lieux destinés à l'hygiène
corporelle
en effet on y venait pour se laver dans
différents d'un dans des eaux chaudes et
froides mais les termes public
comprenait aussi des latrines des
toilettes collectives et même des lieux
pour manger on est dans des lieux
collectifs
on partage la même eau les mêmes espaces
et pour vous essuyez après avoir fait la
grosse commission vous partager aussi la
même éponge
parce que non le papier toilette
n'existe pas à l'époque des bonnes eaux
chaudes en échange de fluides corporels
et notamment de celle de la nourriture
l'endroit idéal pour rattraper tout un
tas de maladies infectieuses et
transmissibles les malades en
particulier les diarrhéiques fréquentes
abondamment ces lieux sur conseils de
leur médecin et il contamine rapidement
les bains on sait à notre époque la
difficulté de maintenir propre une
piscine publique qui on n'a pas d'autre
choix que d'exterminer les germes à
grand renfort de litres de chlore sous
la rome antique la bastide clair on
oublie donc ces lieux supposés
hygiénique sont paradoxalement parmi les
plus cradingue qu'ils soient les romains
adorait venir avec des poudres des
onguents et des huiles pour leur bain
qui se mélangent à l'eau chaude
un vrai bouillon de culture et vous
savez ce qui se passe lorsque plein
d'individus se réunissent dans les mêmes
endroits avec des lieux collectifs ou en
partage aliments comme excréments
non sans déconner deviner ce sont les
épidémies de masse
l'urbanisation galopante la création de
routes le commerce terrestres et
maritimes facilite les échanges entre
les cités c'est un véritable réseau qui
se tissent entre les populations pour
échanger des produits et des richesses
mais pas seulement on va également
s'échanger nos malades
les plus contagieuses et celles ci vont
pouvoir atteindre des villages et des
cités de plus en plus éloignés mais ce
qui marche vachement bien quand on veut
échanger plein de maladies infectieuses
avec ses voisins c'est la guerre et
autant vous dire que dans l'antiquité on
adore se taper sur la tronche et bien
entendu les mouvements de troupes les
champs de bataille les sièges forme ce
doux mélange de promiscuité humaine
d'hygiène inexistante de blessure de
famine et de rationnement une situation
qui affaiblit durablement les défenses
immunitaires et permet à tous les
parasites et micro-organismes de faire
des ravages et toutes les épidémies qui
ont dévasté les villes seront à l'époque
appelé sans distinction est sans que ça
n'ait forcément rapport avec la vraie
peste celle véhiculée par le bacille
hier sans la plus dure à légumes on est
tous à la peste d'athènes contemporaine
de la guerre du péloponnèse et d'après
les descriptions clinique probablement
provoquées par un typhon segment
thématique est transmise par
l'intermédiaire des poux elle va
provoquer la mort du dirigeant d'athènes
périclès et d'un tiers de la population
de la cité au bas mot amorçant le déclin
des cités grecques qui était alors à
leur apogée la peste antonine quant à
elle contemporaine du règne de marc
aurèle est probablement d'origine
orientale
son explosion dans l' empire romain
correspond à l'établissement d'une
ambassade à jay-z dans l' empire de
chine de la dynastie and subissant
depuis au moins 15 ans
les ravages d'une épidémie inconnu cette
peste entre guillemets d'après les
descriptions réalisé par gallien
contemporain de la période pourrait
s'apparenter à une épidémie de variole
qui va rapidement se propager dans tout
l'empiré romain
elle sera responsable d'une mortalité de
7 à 10% voire 15% en zone urbaine
aggravée par les famines les guerres et
la pression fiscale de l'époque soit au
total 7 à 10 millions de morts pour un
empire qui comprend 64 millions
d'individus en 164 après jésus-christ
mais il n'ya pas que les infections de
masse d'autres maladies infectieuses
plus chronique et moins rapidement
mortelle vont profiter de la période
antique pour s'implanter durablement
comme la tuberculose la brucellose ou la
lettre par exemple pour les maladies
infectieuses
on rappelle qu'il n'y avait aucune
méthode de protection efficace à
l'époque en dehors des mesures
d'isolement des malades pas de vaccin
pas d'antibiotiques
donc ok les mecs étaient un peu limités
pour gérer les épidémies bon mais il
savait faire des trucs carrément badass
il a lui même commencé à faire de la
neurochirurgie
parlant d'une des opérations les plus
fascinantes de cette période la
trépanation la trépanation c'est tout
simplement le fait de retirer un morceau
de l'os du crâne d'un individu encore
vivant c'est ce qu'on appelle un volet
osseux durant l'antiquité les exemples
de trépanation sont assez nombreux sans
qu'on en comprenne vraiment la raison
cette pratique a été décrit par
hippocrate sayles héliodore gallien pour
ne citer que les auteurs les plus connus
à noter que les structures vasculaires
et notamment le sinus veine
longitudinale qui chemine entre les deux
hémisphères cérébraux sont soigneusement
évité lors de ces procédures
témoignant d'en savoir un atomique on
faisait pas ça n'importe comment
et on voit clairement que lorsque
l'opération est pratiqué trop près de
cette zone
le patient décède avant même que la
trépanation soit terminée mais la
trépanation existe bien avant
l'antiquité
revenons à nos paysans préhistoriques
les populations néolithiques en europe
l'a pratiqué avec succès on a plusieurs
exemples de crâne perforé depuis le 6e
millénaire avant jésus-christ qui ont
cicatrisé
le taux de succès peut être déterminée
grâce notamment aux signes de
cicatrisation osseuse
parce que logiquement quand on est mort
on cicatrice plus s'il existe ça
démontre que l'individu a survécu
pendant au moins plusieurs semaines
voire plusieurs mois
ce taux de succès durant le néolithique
est estimé aux alentours de 70 % d'après
les deux sites majeurs de sépulture
néolithique sur le territoire français
et notamment lozère sur les grands
causses ce qui suggère qu'il existe un
savoir empirique quant à sa réalisation
est probablement un individu dédié à
cette procédure
par analogie avec les pratiques
empiriques de trépanation du 19e siècle
on peut supposer que si le geste était
réalisé c'était pour soulager des
symptômes en lien avec ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'hypertension
intracrânienne certains problèmes
médicaux comme des saignements ou un
gonflement un oedème cérébral peuvent
donner une compression cérébral qui
entraîne nausées vomissements maux de
tête vertiges et troublée de la vision
si cette compression cérébrale n'est pas
traitée rapidement elle peut provoquer
ce qu'on appelle un engagement c'est à
dire que l'hémisphère comprimé va se
déplacer et comprimer d'autres
structures comme l'autre hémisphère ou
le tronc cérébral et en prennent et à ce
moment des symptômes neurologiques
gravissime et pouvant provoquer le décès
ouvrir un volet eau se permettrait de
soulager cette hypertension
intracrânienne d'améliorer les symptômes
et d'empêcher ce phénomène d'engagement
afin d'éviter le décès
le temps que les saignements se
tarissent tout simplement ou que
l'oedème se résorbe donc depuis des
millénaires on voit émerger des notions
de pharmacopée et des soins médicaux
d'hygiène rudimentaire et même très tôt
de chirurgie les hommes doivent leur
survie à leurs composantes sociales à
l'entr'aide et à la solidarité envers
leurs éléments les plus faibles et les
plus fragiles
au final la médecine n'est qu'un outil
dans près de social parmi d'autres une
manière de soigner les corps pour
renforcer et structurer de groupe que ce
soit en aidant une mère a accouché une
jambe va se réparer en soulageant
l'individu qui souffrent ou en
accompagnant simplement les malades
la médecine est elle née ou at elle été
inventé un jour comme ça ou est ce
simplement un des principes fondateurs
de l'humanité telle que nous la
connaissons
cette vidéo a été réalisée avec le
concours de clotilde et l ajustement une
chaîne youtube qui s'appelle pas ces
sauvages c'est une chaîne qui
t'expliquent l'archéologie à l'époque
antique ou à la préhistoire sentent
raconter de conneries et qui te permet
de savoir à quoi servait cefalu sans
bière qu'on appelle menhir par exemple
pour une fois je vous demande d'aller
vous abonner et profiter ce contenu qui
campe ultra riches et qui cassent times
des ours en termes de vulgarisation
naturellement si la vidéo tu as plus tu
peux la spam et de pouce bleus activer
la cloche pour voir toutes mes vidéos
posé plein de questions en commentaire
et abonnés ou pas hein tu es libre de
tes actes tu fais ce que tu veux dans ta
vie
[Musique]